i spent most of the game just super
confused
trying to figure out what i was doing
with my life
i don't think i've ever been so like
confused
playing someone from argentina i'll play
d4
maybe i'll play like a main line d4
and not play london
yeah let's play c4 i don't almost ever
play this move
are we going to see a banco do i even
know what to play against banko
wait there's a cool line oh what's the
line here
there's something called the nest cafe
frappe attack
is it e4
there's like a really cool variation
which i wanted to like show
how to play
it could be e4
i forget
what am i forgetting
queen of three there's a cool line where
like you sacked the pawn then you
smothered me
i forget the move after 94 though which
is kind of important oh black's not even
taking it
well there goes my opening prop
i guess i could still
[Music]
go for this
i have no idea what i'm doing here
also thanks for subbing oh thanks for
gifting a sub schnellow
gifting a sub to the senate 17.
okay i'm trying to gamble at the pawn so
i open the file and
maybe eventually checkmates finally
black
takes a bait
again i have no idea what i'm doing
you just bishop d ideas like bishop d3
there's a queen e2 play bishop d3 first
i'm gonna have to look into this nest
cafe frappe attack
i saw like a single youtube video about
it
a long time ago i just remember like you
allow b4 you put the knight here and
then you do cool stuff
i mean now the problem is here here here
a6
if my knight's just trapped
[Music]
i could play queenie too
queen e2 is kind of nifty but then takes
i'll play this first
mm-hmm
this could end terribly i just lost i'm
down two pawns now i'm down a ton of
time too
but i don't want to let people down who
predicted i would keep my winning streak
i mean on the bright side
i'm not getting mated i'm also attacking
this pawn and this pawn
but not really this pawn because bishop
a6
but this pawn is looking juicy
i guess black just wants a castle
i mean let's go for it i wonder if black
realized
i could take probably did
okay bishop and pond have a nice
relationship
but yeah they're about to perish
um
i don't like the feeling of this oh i
have this move
actually it's kind of complicated this
is a pin attack
fork both knights are attacked
if takes i think i get away with this
it's so weird what is the structure i
have a past pawn
[Music]
hmm
and block's gonna have a ton of
compensation
[Music]
wait i can i sack the queen
that was a nifty move
wait a minute i can take
what's material
i'm so confused
i think i'm in trouble wait i have this
oh oh the pawn's not queen oh wait in
this queening
what is this what just happened
the queen is reborn or reincarnated
it came back to life
oh yes my queen
i feel so alive now i'm also up a rook
oh no i'm up exchange
but down on time
wow the structure is a little bit
grotesque
my beautiful position
there goes my knight wait i'm up two
exchanges
i can't count i'm so confused how am i
up to exchanges
i'm so baffled i'm not flagging yet
oh this pawn's tender this pawn's
defended too
queen f7 i'll play rook a6
attack laterally
[Music]
so i want to play this move
i have no time maybe this move too
[Music]
some idea okay let's start with this
am i winning this pot wait black has no
good way to defend the pawn i might just
be winning here i guess as this move
takes
a blockade
now this should be a simple win as long
as i don't flag
and this is a horsemaid threat
opponent is realizing their doom
there's like one tricky move
oh
guys half expecting something like this
i'm just trying to scoop up the pawn
okay how did i win that i spent most of
the game just
super confused trying to
figure out what i was doing with my life
i don't think i've ever been so like
confused
like from the opening and then i guess i
wasn't aware of the material situation
it was such a weird sequence too
[Music]
i lost two pawns in the opening
and then i proceeded to win back two
pawns because uh this is kind of a neat
setup but then the problem was the
center opened up and my
king was not castle and these pieces
were slow to develop
but somehow i kind of made it work
stockfish just says black's winning here
let's shun stockfish
so when i took here i knew i was getting
some material
and then
i considered this line initially and
thought i'm guaranteed to queen
but the queen the queen covers d8 so
black
black just had to move the knight to a
square which doesn't block this diagonal
but thankfully for me black played
knight c7 and
my queen was
i'm struggling with the words today
promoted
yeah my pawn was promoted
and the yeah the queen was reborn
oh yeah i have to show also what was the
what the the nest cafe attack
um
yeah i'll do that as soon as i can just
reflect on what just happened
i'm trying to count material
oh so in this position
i guess i in the moment i thought i was
up the exchange
which is only half true i was up an
exchange and a rook
for a pawn so when i ended up losing a
rook
or no losing a piece then i was up
basically two exchanges
so it all worked out okay
yeah that was youtube worthy well i
still have to show the nest cafe attack
nice cafe coffee
pods no attack
aha
okay
what is this this is a one of the first
responses
this is not the nes cafe
this is like dumb bong cloud
no offense um
wait let me find
oh here we go okay thank you chess.com
this is a nice cafe
wait how does this how does this come to
be
oh i'm supposed to take oh takes a nanny
for
no knight c3 i'm so confused
knight c3 okay the move order is
important
okay i knew at some point the knight
should go to b5 so it's a more specific
move order
so let's show it on this board so
here yeah for those that don't know this
is a banco gambit
and um it's an interesting way of
playing like
black goes for some positional sacrifice
so we accept the gambit first
a6 is very typical and then
knight c3 is a move
which i guess initially is known as the
zleitsev system
e takes b5 and then e4
right yeah e4
here b4
knight b5 and here we see
the nest cafe frappe attack so i wasn't
fully going insane
i just forgot to move order
and there's there's some really cool
lines here because it looks like
we look at this position when white
plays e4 it looks like black just wins a
pawn
because you remove the guard and then
you win the pawn
uh the points and we can check the
database here
that's incredible if black takes a pawn
white is
uh is winning 85 percent of the time
i think i mentioned this uh at some
point in in my opening that there's some
idea of smother mates
so here queen e2 281 victims played
knight
f6 and okay most got mated
that's a cool smother mating idea
why is it called the nes cafe frappe
attack i have no idea
it's probably named after mr attack
let's go thanks gary
sobbing for eight months welcome back
so i think it's just bad for black to
take the pawn
because the light's pinned basically to
the idea of smother mates
and you can't really counter attack
because when you take the knight you
defend with the bishop
also thanksgiving subbing with prime
so the better approach here we can even
check with engine
unshun stockfish actually f5 is probably
the best move
go away windows but then f3
yeah white's just winning a piece
f5 it looked like it defended the knight
which it did and gave a square for the
king
the problem is again wherever the knight
moves this is still mate because the
knight covers f7
so
f3 always play off three
um
yeah so this pawn is literally poison
so the battery move is d6 here
and then
so shots.com is showing bishop c4
but bishop f4 is more plain
yeah bishop f4 seems to be
perhaps uh the move to go for
[Music]
wow g5 okay this is masters database
let's check lee chess database
what does g5 i guess g5 is maybe like a
prepared move
it looks natural to play knight d7
and then
i guess there's some eventual idea of e5
like g6 looks natural and then e5 and
uh if takes we can follow the most
played moves the problem for black this
is now a threat
bishop g7 we play this and knight c7
coming
and if takes takes and knight c7 is
still
pretty much unstoppable so it's a cool
opening
like if you're a mainline d4 player
and you want a weapon against the banco
i guess first it's a matter of
remembering the move order
but the nest cafe frappe attack
a nice aggressive sort of counter gambit
so anyway if this goes on youtube this
will maybe be a longer youtube video for
a single game
but i hope some of this is is valuable
hope you enjoyed the game
and be sure to follow on twitch
subscribe on youtube
and i'll see you in the future